hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be explaining every blood demon art that
has been introduced in the demon Slayers
story up to this point blood demon arts
also known as blood demon techniques are
unique special powers and abilities that
higher-level demons possess and when I
first started watching the Demon Slayer
Anna made the blood demon arts along
with the unique breath styles of the
demon Slayers were the two things that
really grabbed my interest right away
since I've already made a video
explaining every known breath style it
only makes sense to also make a video
talking about every blood demon art
right here in one place for your
convenience I also want to give a
special shout out to all of you who
requested this specific video in the
comments of our previous videos I do
read the comments and I do really
appreciate all of your feedback and
requests thank you if you enjoyed the
demon slayer content on this channel and
you'd like to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell just before we get
into it a huge thank you to Saint Seiya
Awakening Knights of the zodiac for
sponsoring this video
Saint Seiya awakening is a strategy
role-playing game with high-definition
3d graphics it is an impressive anime
mobile game which perfectly restores the
classic Japanese franchise Saint Seiya I
grew up with the Saint Seiya aka Knights
of the zodiac franchise and I'm super
excited that this game is officially
licensed by the Creator masami kurumada
and I'm happy too this game restores the
story of the classic manga the twelve
golden Saints and all classic Saint
Seiya characters are back in sanctuary
and waiting for your summon Saint Seiya
awakening has incredible gameplay
exceptional graphics and fantastic
special effects but that's not all
Saint Seiya awakening features some of
my favorite anime voice actors of all
time including Jun Fukuyama the voice of
Lelouch from cold Geass and Yuki Kaji
the voice of Eren Jaeger from attack on
Titan dude it does not get any better
than this
try it out for yourself right now click
the link in the description to download
saint seiya and jump into the epic anime
action the game is full of incredible
skill combinations that you can use
to gain crucial strategic advantages and
your victory really does depend on your
strategy you can play player versus
player or player versus environment and
if you download the game right now you
will also be helping out this channel
just click the link in the description
it's free for Android and iOS burn your
cosmos the classic is back and finally
spoiler warning in this video I will be
talking about the powers of demons who
have not yet been introduced in the
anime but I will only be talking about
their blood demon arts I will not be
spoiling their backstories or what
ultimately happens to them in the story
so you don't have to worry about me
spoiling too much of the plot itself
with that said use your own discretion
it is important to know that blood demon
art powers vary greatly among the
different demons but they all involve
some form of physical transformation or
manipulation of the demon's body and/or
the demons blood the first blood demon
art that we encounter is the swamp
demon's ability to create a pocket
dimension that is full of thick muddy
water that is similar in texture to
swamp water this technique can appear as
just a small puddle on the ground or
some other surface but it can then
expand to trap the demon's target on the
inside the swamp demon has the ability
to swim very quickly and effectively
through the swamp pocket dimension that
he creates but others who enter the
dimension find it very difficult to move
and they also find it impossible to
breathe inside the swamp space the swamp
demon has a secondary ability which
allows him to split himself into three
different bodies each of the bodies
wears different clothing and has either
one two or three horns on its head
two of the three bodies remain
intelligent but one becomes an
animalistic creature who instead of
speaking is only capable of making the
most annoying sound known to mankind and
no ZENIT's whose constant screaming and
crying is not nearly as annoying as any
to his best boy and his cries are like
ASMR to my ears next up we have a lady
Tama yo she has a blood demon art
referred to as blood bewitchment and
this power allows her to influence other
people with the smell of her blood the
scent of her blood can produce
hallucinations it can force people to
tell the truth
can even reduce their brain function and
she is able to use her own flesh and
blood to produce seeds that sprout into
large flesh trees with spiked branches
that can pin and restrain even the most
powerful opponents we also have ushido
who has the ability to mask or reveal
the presence of someone or something
with the help of a paper talisman he is
also able to hide his own presence which
makes him practically invisible
according to ushiro his blood demon art
is still incomplete
meaning that he may yet developed new
powers and abilities sometime in the
future we'll have to wait and see now
let's talk about the tamari demon Susa
Maru her ability is pretty simple she
can conjure up the balls which she then
chucks at her opponents but these are no
ordinary balls these balls have a lot of
destructive power and they can rip
through a building and even smash
through a demon super-powered limbs so
someone who is definitely the ultimate
handball player but her blood demon art
definitely isn't one of the most
powerful once I mean they're balls next
let's talk about yah haba also known as
the arrow demon this mad lad has eyes on
the palms of his hands and using these
eyes he can sense and track his targets
including their footprints he can also
launch arrows from his hands and anyone
who comes into contact with these arrows
is forced to move in the direction that
the arrow is pointing yah haba appears
to be able to control the arrows even
after launching them then we have the
one and only Nazca Komodo
the most adorable deadly demon of them
all Nez eCos blood demon art allows her
to set her own blood on fire and she can
use this fire either to burn demons to
death or to do less lethal things like
burn the poison out of a human's body
without actually killing the human Nez
Zuko is also able to combine her fiery
blood with the unique powers and
abilities of other characters including
her brother Tom zero and this teamwork
leads to more complex and more effective
attacks I won't get into too many
specifics because I don't want to get
into spoiler territory but if you are
interested in learning more about Nez
Zuko's unique demon powers you can check
out an entire video I made on a Zuko's
power link in the description now let's
talk about yokai also known as the drum
Kyoukai is a member of the 12 demon
moons although he is lower moon 6 which
means he is the weakest out of the 12
demon moons youkai is able to rotate the
rooms inside of his mansion by hitting
the - drums on his shoulders to move the
room left or right or the - drums on his
legs to move the room forward or
backward the drum on his chest allows
him to launch a powerful claw attack and
his opponent and the drum on his back
allows him to teleport into a different
room within his mansion by drumming
faster all of his abilities become even
stronger and more effective and now
we've come to the creepiest family since
the zoldak s' the demon spider family
let's start with the pretty boy of the
group which is definitely the father I
mean this guy has the face of a kpop
star and we all know it
the father's blood demon art is the
ability to shed his skin totally not
gross and transform into an even more
powerful form in this new form he is
stronger more durable and he is able to
regenerate even faster than before the
mother of the spider family is able to
attach spiderweb threads to her targets
the threads are spread by little white
spiders that are controlled by the
mother and the threads may appear
invisible at first unless you're paying
really close attention because of how
fine they are once the threads are
attached the mother can manipulate her
target like a puppet forcing the target
to move and even fight others against
their will this technique can be used on
both humans and demons and it can even
be used on corpses the older sister of
the family has the ability to trap her
prey inside a web cocoon which then
dissolves the victim over time using
some sort of acidic substance the older
brother of the family has the ability to
transform humans into spider like
creatures by injecting them with a
poisonous venom if the transformation is
successful the target will become a
spider like monster without a will of
their own and they will simply follow
the orders of the older brother spider
and finally we have Rui the powerful
demon who established the spider demon
family in the first place Rui is
actually a member of MU sans 12 demon
moons and his rank is lower moon 5 this
means that he is the second weakest
demon moon our
twelve he is also the most needy spoiled
sibling you will ever meet in your life
Louie has the ability to create
spiderweb like strings that can slice
his targets into pieces he can use these
strings to create various forms of
deadly attacks including outright
slicing his opponents trapping them
inside a deadly spider web cage or
creating a rotating wheel made up of
threads that are capable of cutting
through opponents with ease next up
let's talk about lower moon one and move
the seventh strongest demon moon and the
strongest lower demon moon an mo has the
ability to put his opponents to sleep
and then enter their dreams he can
control and manipulate the dreams of his
targets and he can even kill them in
their sleep if he is able to destroy
their spiritual core within the dream
which in turn destroys their mind and mu
can also allow other individuals to
enter his opponents dreams instead of
him and he can then rely on those other
people to do his dirty work for him now
let's talk about ducky she is able to
turn her body or parts of her body into
a thin sash like substance basically
imagine a thin sash made out of cloth
ducky can make her body take on the
texture and appearance of such a sash or
sashes she can then move quickly through
incredibly narrow spaces she can slash
her opponents with the sashes and she
can even detach parts of her from the
main body and use these parts as
sentient spies or guards which allow her
to keep an eye on things even when her
main body is located somewhere else
entirely
then we have goo taro another extremely
powerful demon who attained the rank of
upper moons six he has the ability to
create sights from his own flesh and
blood and you taro has incredibly
precise and deadly control of these
weapons the sites have both long range
and short range capabilities as well as
both offensive and defensive properties
which makes them very effective weapons
his sights are extremely deadly not only
are they sharp but they are also coated
in poison which allows guitarra to
strike a fatal blow to his opponents
even when the cut itself would not be
fatal we also can't forget kai Kaku
another one of the upper moons
as a human he was able to use the breath
of thunder style the same breath style
that is used by Senna - and as a demon
his abilities and attacks are
strengthened further however because he
has only been a demon for a short time
kai Kaku has not yet had a chance to
develop all of his demonic powers so we
don't know any more specific details
about his potential blood demon art next
up is Yoko a water-themed demon who
attained the rank of upper moon five his
blood demon art gives him a wide variety
of very useful and creepy abilities he
carries a bunch of pots wherever he goes
and he has the ability to instantly
teleport from one part to the other in
order to avoid attack he can also summon
deadly fish demons and tentacles from
these pots and unleash them upon his
enemies on top of that he also possesses
a powered up form which makes him even
stronger as his body becomes covered in
incredibly hard scales these scales are
said to be even harder than diamonds now
let's talk about hunting GU the upper
moon for hunting goose blood demon art
allows him to split his body into
several different forms each guided by
its own primary emotion this includes
kérékou or joy who uses a fan in the
shape of a leaf to generate large gusts
of wind strong enough to take down an
entire building we also have Isis or
sorrow who uses a long spear that can be
extended or shrunk at will and yogi or
pleasure
who has large wings and bird-like talons
haruki can use sonic sound waves to
attack his opponents and you can also
create miniature clones of himself
there is also haunting goo or fear a
smaller version of the original hunting
goo but with increased durability udemy
or resentment a larger and stronger
version of hunting goo with armor like
defensive power and sexy doe or anger
who can generate lightning based attacks
using his staff sekito is also able to
absorb other clones in order to create a
more powerful version of himself called
zou hokotan
or hatred so he's kind of a demon
Voltron then we have na ki met another
upper moon who is close to Mouzon she
uses the Japanese traditional instrument
known as a bee WA to manipulate and
control the dimensional infinity
fortress
Mouzon uses as a gathering place for the
demon moons she is able to summon anyone
she wishes into the fortress and she can
also manipulate the building itself
shifting its position and creating
doorways wherever she wishes
in addition na kima has the ability to
detach eyeballs from her body and use
them to effectively spy on her targets
from a great distance next up we have a
casa the upper moon three demon and my
brother goes ins favorite upper moon as
a human a casa was a martial artist who
used a barehanded fighting style and as
a demon his blood demon art essentially
turns him into a superhuman martial
artist he uses powerful physical attacks
mostly punches and kicks which create
massive shock waves and he has the
ability to sense his opponents bloodlust
and detect where his opponents attacks
are coming from now let's talk about
DOMA also known as upper moon - his
blood demon art basically allows him to
create various ice based attacks such as
razor sharp wind gusts freezing ice
clouds ice lotuses ice piers and even
small ice clones of himself that can
fight his opponents for him his most
powerful attack allows him to create a
massive ice statue that uses ice based
attacks to assault his targets and now
we get to the strongest upper moon upper
moon one kakushi bow this demon is
capable of using his own unique breath
style called breath of the moon but he
does also have other demonic abilities
his blood demon art allows him to
separate a part of his own flesh from
his body and turn it into a sword this
sword is covered with demonic eyes and
kakushi bow frequently uses it in battle
the eyes and the sword increased a range
of his vision and because the sword is
made of his own demonic flesh kakushi
bow can changed the shape and size of
the blade and encase the blade is
damaged he can easily repair it since a
demon's flesh can quickly regenerate
this demon is a master swordsman and his
power is equivalent to the power of
multiple Hasina's put together believe
it or not there is also a human who is
not a demon but who seems to be
developing his own form of a blood demon
art gained Yoshino tsugawa the brother
of the wind hashira son ami has a unique
ability which allows him to temporarily
demonic powers after consuming the flesh
of a demon even though he himself
remains human so he is basically the
hawk of demon slayer when he absorbs
parts of a really strong demon like an
upper moon
ganya begins manifesting some of their
powers and characteristics which of
course makes him much stronger than
usual he can regenerate quickly just
like a demon he has increased strength
and durability and he can even develop
something akin to a blood demon art for
example after absorbing components of
two different upper moons
ganya is able to control the bullet that
he shoots from his gun in Supernatural
ways and he is able to transform the
bullets into tree branches once they are
lodged inside his intended target which
drastically constricts the target's
ability to move we will have to wait and
see how Kenya's powers developed further
and whether any of his powers will
actually become permanent he is just
such an outlier in the series when it
comes to power that it is very hard to
pin down his power and its true nature
and finally we have a moose on Kabuto G
the original demon and the progenitor of
all the other demons Mouzon has many
unique powers and abilities and I would
need an entire video to talk about them
all but for this video it is enough to
mention that he possesses a blood demon
art that allows him to manipulate his
blood and flesh in many useful and
deadly ways not only can he turn humans
into demons by making them in just his
blood but he can also shape-shift use
certain forms of telepathy absorb other
beings into himself and create deadly
objects out of his flesh such as spiked
barbed wire he also has an impeccable
fashion sense and he has been compared
to a young Michael Jackson and those are
all the blood demon arts that have been
introduced so far unless I miss some in
which case please do let me know down in
the comments by the way which of these
blood demon arts is your personal
favorite and if you could create your
own blood demon art for yourself what
would it be let me know down below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more videos like it please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
seriously if you want to get notified on
youtube you have to hit the bell and
turn on all notifications otherwise
YouTube will bury our videos it's just
how it works feel free to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram
at Anime uproar for all the latest demon
slayer news and updates once again I'm
big thank you to Saint Seiya awakening
Knights of the zodiac for generously
sponsoring this video what I love about
this game is that it doesn't pretend to
be an anime s came this is a genuine
anime game based on a classic anime and
manga franchise
it features epic j-pop and j-rock music
that will keep you pumped up while you
play and as I said before it boasts some
of my favorite anime voice actors
including the Japanese voice of Lelouch
and the Japanese voice of Eren Yeager as
a massive anime fan it really doesn't
get much better than that for me
especially since we're talking about a
game with amazing graphics incredible
moves and gripping strategic elements
that is nevertheless free to download on
Android and iOS whether you're a fan of
San Seiya or new to the franchise this
game will keep you entertained and
immersed in the fantastical world of
Saint Seiya try it out for yourself
right now just click the link in the
description to download Saint Seiya
awakening and jump into the anime action
and strategy I'm a big fan of strategy
games myself and the skill combinations
in this game are absolutely gripping and
once you realize how the game mechanics
work you will see that good strategy is
the key to winning this game you can
play a player versus player or player
versus environment and if you download
the game right now you will also be
helping out this channel just click the
link in the description like I said it's
free for Android and iOS as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]